-Hey, guys, it's time to take
a look at the stories
making headlines today
and weigh the good with the bad.
It's time for "Pros and Cons."
Here we go.
-♪ Pros and cons and pros
and cons and pros ♪
-Tonight, we'll be taking a look
at the pros and cons
of Biden's infrastructure bill.
-Whoo!
-That's right. Today --
Really?
-Alright!
-Yeah. That's right.
Today, President Biden signed
a roughly $1 trillion
bipartisan
infrastructure bill into law
during a White House
signing ceremony.
So, let's take a look at
the pros and cons
of the infrastructure bill.
Here we go. Pro...
Con...
-Oh.
-Yeah.
-It's already topping the chart.
Pro...
Con...
So, hey...
-Hey!
-Why not?
-It's delicious. Pro...
Con...
Pro...
Ooh!
-Ooh!
Ooh, snap!
-Pro...
Con...
"Raphael found this
great place on Zillow."
-Oh, Michelangelo.
-Pro...
Con...
-What?!
-Now, that's interesting.
All the...
Pro...
Con...
He's earned it.
Imagine how many times a day
he has to say that?
-Yeah. He sits there.
-Yeah, he sits there.
-He's a pro. He's a pro.
-Pro...
Con...
Finally...
There you have it.
Those are our "Pros and Cons."